you
hey here we are again everybody and
welcome to pep talks I'm Eddie Pepitone
and you know me as the bitter Buddha my
wife just goes hey where is the thing
she doesn't really say the bitter Buddha
hey bitter Buddha where is the thing but
let me let me give you a little
introduction and by the way I think you
could tell already that my voice is
pretty even-keeled today and that I
didn't start the podcast so I've going
hello and welcome everybody in that fake
way so I think it's going to be a good
one let me just give you a couple of
dates Vancouver hello I am at the
rickshaw theatre in Vancouver on October
sixteenth and then I go to perhaps the
country's intellectual center Peoria
Illinois Illinois i'm at the jukebox
comedy club october twenty second to
24th los angeles you want to know my
show blood bath which is an amazing show
and i do it once a month it returns to
the hollywood improv on friday October
thirtieth the night before All Hallows
Eve where people get murdered for fun
now we sold out the last one don't miss
this one and ticket links are at Eddie
Pepitone calm and now let's get to the
good part my guest is Wake is a funny
stand-up he's such an interesting stand
up I just listened to his stand-up album
Fairbanks on Apple music I listen I
subscribe to Apple music and you're on
it and and he's a writer he you've seen
him on fuel TV did you host a show on
fuel TV occasionally towards the end
when the show was about to be canceled
they took a couple last-minute stabs at
letting me host I like that and he does
a great podcast that I've been on it's
called do you need a ride with Karen
kill Gareth we've been a guest on the
show please welcome Chris Fairbanks
Eddie about your dates coming up it
seems like you're doing a pretty legit
Vancouver theatre gig and then you're
doing albeit its historic but a pretty
small B room tell me what net see Orion
oh no have you done it I have they own
headline me that the things you don't
like nobody it you will have so much fun
there that's all I that's a that's a
town that Sam Kinison and both Richard
Pryor from I didn't they take pride in
them there's murals of them on the walls
so the whole town is kind of trained
even if they are you know wearing a hat
that says fart on it and don't have
sleeves and they're on a tractor they
will they're pretty savvy would stand up
you're gonna look like [ __ ] and there's
a strip club right next door oh hey hey
hi just high-five take it put it on
because a lot of strippers you know yeah
near the end of their life and you just
are like put it on I want to see you get
dressed before you die put it on oh my
god may I quote you love it may I quote
a bill burr joke because I actually I
actually you know I listen to you I was
in Atlanta this weekend and again this
isn't to hurt anybody or to make anybody
feel less than that I had this kind of
lifestyle but I headlined the Laughing
Skull and when I go on the road for that
one see it's about 80 go ahead which I
have trouble filling um um but I I when
I do stand up now you do you go and do
stand-up on weekends and [ __ ] do you do
that stuff yeah it's an amazing learning
experience like I've come to it late
where I headline and where I go on these
trips and I'm like it's all about you
know Eddie Pepitone headlining and so
these you know and hour-long sets in
front of crowds to me are just they can
be so frightening I've gotten used to
him I've now done it for about four
years running but holy [ __ ] I'm like
fernet like right now I'm exhausted and
I'm loving the fact that i'm going to
Orlando I for a comedy festival and and
Vancouver there one show you know just
one [ __ ] show right an hour and I'm
gone yeah and what I love about that is
that the the club thing can be such a
[ __ ] grind I haven't done that for a
while I did that more when I was
featuring 4p and I just did feature
featuring is about 25 Z so is that's by
the way that's perfect yeah the 20 25
minutes set it's a it's perfect I wish I
could feature for the money I get for
headlining yeah and then my life would
be good I think everyone would like that
hahahaha i'm not saying i'm a-- i'm a
maverick in that thought but there are
so many flaws with the club thing just
doing those five to six shows i haven't
been doing much of that i'm just trying
to get these places where you have and
it's that's great that you're at the
point where you're just people are like
hey Eddie's in town well well yeah let's
let's back up a little bit it's it's
it's it's building a little bit but it's
hard I've watched it build and I know
exactly where your careers at its hahaha
okay it is and cuz are you an optimistic
guy I feel like you are because you seem
happy because because like I always some
get the glass half empty because I'm
always like a [ __ ] instead of thinking
all my career's building I'm like this
is me I'm like I [ __ ] i only have a
certain window here for it to build well
because that's true yeah yeah so it's
okay you're being realistic yeah I guess
so and if we like my best friends that
like I hang out with Henry Phillips a
lot only the most negative all we do is
complain isn't right laugh so hard yeah
would you laugh he's not joking yeah
he's like yeah that's [ __ ] oh you
know who else I hate and I'm laughing we
have so much fun at such a positive
Henry being negative Henry Phillips
those you don't know such a funk mean
he's got the voice of a guy who's been
coal mining for 75 years meaning he's
got a gravelly I don't know I guess I've
been coal mine in her man I don't know
17 years with the [ __ ] but uh yeah you
don't like it in Peoria what you're
funny guy but I want to get back to the
bill bill better order what I was doing
was I was listening to a bunch of
stand-ups because I had just come off a
show it was a Saturday night late show
at the Laughing Skull and there were a
bunch of frat boys there and they were
just talking and I had to [ __ ]
discipline them and I am the worst
I am the worst crowd work meeting when
they're [ __ ] being [ __ ] because
what I do is I just go shut the [ __ ] up
you stupid [ __ ] I want to do my comedy
and you know it turns the rest of the
audience a little against me because
I've been so brutal to these [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean you know
they're on your side the rest of the
audience will turn on you once you show
your or or they'll be like this is tense
yeah and it takes a while to dig out of
that hole you know so I went home that
night and it was the late show was the
only show i did six shows and that was
the show that had like a little bit of
like uh you need to you need to like I I
always would attack but not attack
myself I have to show but I'm like I get
very like thoughtful about stand-up like
well if you're gonna keep doing this you
gotta learn how to deal with these
people in a manner that doesn't make
people you know hate you and also you
kind of diffuse it blah blah blah yeah
and so I went home and I just listened
to all this step I never I usually never
listen to other people's stuff I don't
know why that is I think partly I don't
want to hear how good they are like part
of me is afraid that they're gonna be
one way way better than me and then part
of me is like um uh like first I'm
scared there can be way better than me
and then I'm gonna be as scared I'm
gonna get angry and I don't know what it
is but you know I'm I avoided it
sometimes because I didn't want to be
I'm easily influenced like I know when I
hang out with a comic for a while by the
end of the week I'm like doing an
impression of them yeah is why I'm
scared you might take some of their
stuff too or just not so much that you
can usually keep track of that although
I have done that and I'm like God that
seemed familiar haha out of it the past
life and then it's like you know you're
doing one of your best friends premises
there oh well that's maybe why but uh
but also yeah just you know because you
have a unique voice and what it would it
not be as unique if you were listening
to all these other standups well
they sound more like jen kirkman I do
want to hear her special if I hood I
know everybody has told me I don't she
doesn't like me in real life she does it
in real life comedy is a fake land fake
world fig landscape well on stage is a
strange greater sorry special yeah yeah
everybody says that but anyway I was
listening to so one of the communities
into you I listened to burr I listened
to yeah we're on the same level no but
that's an interesting thing man because
you just said it to everybody has their
own [ __ ] voice and it's just [ __ ]
finding it and really now bill really
though she really has his voice and the
[ __ ] special I listened to was from
2010 and it was called let go who and
anyway one of the things in it was so
[ __ ] funny and it we were talking
about strippers me you just say to say
thanks to juke box and it just triggered
this / joke he said I go over it I go
over to my friends place and he's got
this kid this annoying kid and it's one
of these [ __ ] kids whose you know all
he's the parents love them because all
my johnny is so [ __ ] smart and Johnny
we're at dinner and Johnny's flesh
telling me [ __ ] Johnny starts telling
me facts about Jupiter all you know
jumpers got ten [ __ ] moans the all
these bullshitting appearance like oh
isn't he smart and I wanted to say to
Johnny Johnny I saw a stripper quit in
the middle of her set what the [ __ ] do
you have to tell me something about that
like relating that to any knowledge like
come on what are you gonna tell me about
the universe yeah you know the the
wonders of the universe when I've seen
it trooper quit the buddy I mean that
special an hour oh you seen it I thought
you heard it well you're gonna bring up
cuz of the frat boys in Atlanta there's
an added element there cuz you could
they could also turn on you and they're
young agile probably
didn't feed you the boots after the oh
my god that is very true it's an year
old kids except you know and that is
true to that I've reached a point
physically like I've gotten older and I
actually know this is funny because I've
always been kind of like this New York
aggressive guy and I still AM like like
like if like just like like my hackles
go up when I feel threatened in street
or whatever it's just a reaction sure
and I often in my head never in reality
but in my head I'm fighting people all
the [ __ ] time physically but now I
realize I don't think I do very well in
fact here's what I do this looks like a
pen in my pocket it is a pet it isn't
it's it's pepper spray oh the tongue oh
[ __ ] well now it's gonna go off hahaha
anyway what else is going on I can't
believe I sprayed it it just said a test
to test but I keep doing the pot yeah so
you know a little pepper spray I always
have by the way welcome to men who got
who have pepper spray and is the most
emasculating thing I've ever done for
myself I feel free i also have been
crying more when I when I am because I'm
a tiny person but it is if the world had
no guns never net pepper spray
everything would be fine this will do
like if you spray someone in the eyes
they're like [ __ ] they'll stop doing
whatever they're doing yeah and then
it's up to you whether because that's
illegal you can just go up and spray
people in self-defense right but if
they're a big giant person and they got
neck tattoos of a scorpion yeah you can
spray him and then and then yeah feed
them real of them read your Nikes well
here's the thing at the Laughing i
bought it for a girl I just haha I don't
you yeah yeah I don't want in front I
don't that is a romance if by the way
what's funny I just thought you might
need is someone says me I'm gonna get
you and it looks like a pen well you
know what that sounds great maybe I can
take down your number docks you are
gonna get me huh can I just take down
your number wait a minute this is not
going off I know I would have so many
problems with that it's just a trick pen
I was going
strating it's a like a squirting flower
thought I'd cheer you up I was just
gonna say that I think what would work
better uh would be like a squirting
flower a hand buzzer by the hand but
just shake my hand if you so have you so
won't you like a stick of gum snap ha
gotcha here let me like to sing all for
your boom well you now you're mad and
still have a gun welcome to the clown
school of defense I am chuckles now it's
hard to kick people in the ass with
floppy feet but what I want to show you
is this steel told the steel toed floppy
foot it's gonna be hard to wear if
you're in a car would say a dozen to any
friends by the way that is a complete
myth we don't get into their our tweet
there's usually never more than 35
clowns in a small car actually we as
clowns are against carpooling your elf
lizella like Shriners we all have stock
in dutch shell they got out of the art I
by the way the most clowns if you get
them to stop making blue and animals and
honking their nose we'll talk about
their involvement with halliburton kids
by the way if you have a little extra so
interested in harrah burdens because of
lack a racket go away and II understand
and it's gotta be people supply him
those people in its Halliburton you know
I know and it's just a matter of lining
those weapons of mass constructor do you
like poodles and kids up here to tell
you that right Leon is also gonna be
good as far as getting it all the blue
chip stock lately because they make the
air place and make the drones and drones
make the wedding's go away in
Afghanistan if we could just beat neocon
clowns ryokan cloud love it if I love
that neocon climates just die already
see that viral video Neil I love it hey
kids Lockheed Martin stock is going up
kids and I'll tell you what
because cereals never gonna get stable
Hey look I just made a balloon baby a
human baby whoops it popped that's with
abortion hahaha neocon clouds will be
back after this yep Dick Cheney is one
of the spokes one of the guys luck we
have Neil clown can't this is Cheney
this is my impression training look we
have neo clowns coming on today at three
o'clock here at the New York milk
network of cod casting very funny
there's my exact type of humor that I
enjoy hmm however I'm gonna get packing
a loopback yeah like I don't think I you
know I never felt even remotely like
like I get into it occasionally very
occasionally with people in the crowd
but I never think that they're gonna
like I mean you could add that has to be
a really bad level for them to want to
[ __ ] hit you there is a very viral
moment of burr in philly which is a city
I enjoy being in it's beautiful there's
our everybody the bells everything
they've said well all the bells all
these cracked bells that's why i like
about you by the way listening to your
special is you have this ability like
like you'll go philly odd the bells like
you you're very it's like surreal like
your would you describe it as like what
you do it's like you kind of like this
is what i really like about you and what
we have in common is like you just like
to free-associate like you just like to
we've all and free associate my goal as
people yeah daddy-o hahaha no would you
like to do that I do liked it and that's
to me when it's the most fun when I'm
doing quote unquote stand up when
jazzing around like riffing around like
letting my thoughts go where they go and
let people come on that right and then
when I have to identify your emotion you
get more remote you'll like a range of a
moat I like try and stay pretty well you
save your voice I'm shocked by the end
of us six show run I save my voice by
not I realized listening reason i rarely
finish a thought or is it
just I'm like how can a man I don't want
to I'm like old uh you having Williams
but not on coke I'm just like oh and
then uh what's the next I don't die i'm
an idiot and then I'd like turn on
myself I couldn't listen to my own voice
i don't like listening to myself either
by the way yes but that's kind of a no
sexless muppet from the nasally sexless
Muppet is brought to you by haha Barton
an ass / cream you bet your ass / cream
it's in me I don't know what that means
I don't but you do it but I don't but I
say it with conviction then i was in
philly I every night I felt like the
crowd first of all there's this bar has
the famous maybe a laugh [ __ ] yeah of
him turn and that's how I felt every
night and I'm what's getting shown where
were you at helium Oh your heel up and i
love i love and they like me and they're
nice and I'm like how about next time
Portland I'm like dad haha you mean you
felt a little pressure from the audience
they are they think they're they're like
I'll make its laughs [ __ ] they're a
little like oh oh I see what you're
doing there with your silly [ __ ] out
there and my brother lady psidium yeah
well they love if you grew up with
brothers that had bought you and pull
pranks and yeah I don't know about you
people went from really it's like New
York except without the art they without
the love of the Arts I don't know I'm
from my damn that's pretty true about
philly and I love it's it it it it is it
like in New York with all the culture
and it's you know it's it's like they
have a they have a reputation of being
tough I mean they're if you're a sports
fan they [ __ ] booed Santa Claus right
Philadelphia there if Eagle fans and fly
event they are the kind hey I'm just
busting your balls know it I'm from
Montana we don't bust each other's ball
if you're rude you get punched I don't
know I don't there's a during the day
walking around in a park or something
Montana people are so polite and people
are nice and in philly yes like there's
a make us laugh [ __ ] thing in an
entertainment standpoint they're tough
and everyone thinks they're funny the
homeless there every time
I walked to and from the club in the
hotel homeless would say hey five jokes
for a buck they all would tell jokes and
they weren't having a meeting like hey
let's kind of a comedians some of them
and I'm like hey that guy with one
trouser leg rib yeah is doing your bit
ah I really was hearing the same joke
from different homeless people but and
then they have got stickers I saw a
couple Philly is funny but bumper
stickers someone can confirm this for me
but I think they all are amateur
comedians and jar a little more judgey
during but during why I love the city I
love that you're I love Ali are playing
both sides lira texture no but so then I
a terrific shows by the way what have I
just made no sense they loved me they
love me wait I thought you said haha
okay yeah no I mean you don't part of me
after I had that tough set like late
night on that Saturday with the frat
boys I was so this is gonna sound a
little lame but I was so proud of myself
because what i did was i told her shut
the [ __ ] up right you know and I didn't
pander to them because what I feel like
that crowd wants and I don't do it is
like fat jokes and [ __ ] jokes or that
kind of like like Louis common share
nominated stuff and I just don't do it
not that I'm above it you know because
I'll [ __ ] do whatever I think is
funny in the moment you know but like I
have a certain like game plan going into
a set you know and it's like I was
really for some reason you know I've
gotten very political and for some
reason that weekend and I you know I was
really into talking about how because
like because i'm reading [ __ ] about this
and whatever i'm reading [ __ ] that gets
me going like I'm reassured about how we
spend about sixty percent of our sixty
percent of our money you know on the
military are you reading the billet
freakonomics are you well enough
freakonomics um really look horrified me
but yeah I'm a guy named chris Hedges
who's who's a political writer he's a
Pulitzer Prize winner for the New York
Times and then he got fired for speaking
out against the Iraq war and he's this
guy who to me is that one of the biggest
truth tellers there is
and he points out that you know sixty
percent of you instead of those
resources going to education healthcare
blah blah blah jobs right it's going
toward war and helicopters and drones
and so I'm pissed so I'm legitimately
getting pissed when I read this so I
bring it to the club yeah yeah and I
want to talk about it and so these [ __ ]
they didn't derail me from that like I
shout it wasn't a great set I shouted
them down yes it shut the [ __ ] up you
[ __ ] or whatever I did great crowd
work that would be funny if I said shut
the [ __ ] up you [ __ ] and by the way
where are you from sir you just you
realize after insulting them like you're
in a position of crowd work haha force
it you shut the [ __ ] up but what is this
your way architect would he go long you
been together hello you [ __ ] been
together but you know when when there
are a bunch of people talking and it is
alcohol-fueled I don't know what you can
do against yeah that can you do anything
abyss I it's kind of up to the club to
it's been a while the the worst
situation for me is a drunk person that
is having fun hmm and there quietly
interacting with you and they're
disrupting your your rivet no one's
really noticing except the people around
them so the people around them are like
I wish this guide shut up but they don't
know they're starting to get trained
that it's okay because if someone does
that all the let's go back and forth I'm
quicker than you and I'm amplified so
I'll win but then at one point I'm I get
tired of it and I turn on them and I say
horrible things you do you do quality
and imagine you I get mega man filled
with the anger i I just I usually spend
it on myself until the right person
comes along that describes everybody
thank you so much great I usually all
the bile in me I usually turn inward
until the right person comes along as
packet and I cap it with the fact that
my mom is in hospice and then it's the
moment someone says something I I I get
mad at them for things she did things I
did to myself and like what
I think that is the thing about being a
stand-up is that this is gonna sound a
little pretentious but we are we really
are so [ __ ] vulnerable up there like
work like we're trying to be funny we're
trying to elicit a specific response and
if we don't get it it's almost like and
I've had dreams by the way like this
just humiliation dreams I have you had
this dream as a stand-up I've had this
dream recurring where I'm in front of an
audience and they're all rapt attention
and I don't have anything to say I just
have forgotten what I was going to say
to them right and that's the dream where
I'm in front of them and I'm like um I
used to I don't know what I don't
remember my dreams off and I still just
know what I were you dreaming that I
can't run and my teeth are falling out
I've pretty standard I can't run and my
teeth are falling and I had a guy
clearly 91 and grinding my teeth me but
on stage I will in my head while awake
flash like I wonder what it would be
like to draw a blank right now oh yeah
think of any of my jokes even if things
are going well I still am able to
sabotage just with a weird suggestion
from a devil on my shoulder yes I god
what if I just have a brain fart for
lack of a better term here's what I
think I think happens I think all good
comedians all really good comedians have
that they have and that's what drives
them into comedy is what they're doing
what they're doing is try to try to beat
down that voice with you know jokes and
humor yeah guys like bar bill burr have
one or what they have done is they've
completely what I was so impressed with
built like listening to that special
like I haven't listened like to an hour
like that of him for like I don't know
forever and it's like he takes all his
demons like demon and puts it into the
act like has the courage to put it into
the act yeah and say things that a lot
of people may think are inappropriate
just starting like yeah you listen to I
I don't think anything in there is about
me maybe my stance is on circumcision or
so there's little moma
I actually do care about this I could
see like flashes are you talking about
your family and but I'm ya father what
did you say about your father I forgot
it was early in the set religion or he
said no one crows known crucified Jesus
he was just really clumsy carpenter no
that's a dad joke yeah yeah I forget it
was it was it it was like an aside but I
could tell there was something deeper
and I wish I could remember oh it was
such a funny joke actually they do chris
has this joke where he goes huh my dad
um he he always said that I'm paraphrase
I'm probably [ __ ] it up he always said
that i'm trying to do you let me see it
let me see if i could do you look uh
yeah my god he used to come into the
basement and shows photos of him a
Purple Heart if Purple Heart having a
Purple Heart in the army but it just
turned out to be a picture of him
squeezing his balls I thought that was
like that is a really dark oh yeah that
alienates cement crowds I like the way
you still do it you just fixed it how
you stood it's like yeah it should be
that how did you do it the version i do
takes three minutes and you just did all
the highlights paraphrased it what
people used to complain when back when i
was on Comedy Central that late nineties
hiya they used to like take these
premium blend shows kids it's an old
show yes I think this went off do you
feel peppers yeah I'm sorry being
serious I'm sorry but yeah I feel like I
pepper sprayed myself it's just slowly
seeping out state they would edit
people's jokes down yeah and I never
ones like oh they ruined my joke but for
me what they did i'm like I started
telling him that way I'm like thanks
Comedy Central for trimming the fat the
point it that's what you just did that's
I'm gonna cuz i don't have it be funny
your feature sets don't turn out to be
like you supposed to do 20 but you do
five like you've whittled it down just
press it for me ah i guess with that one
though it is dramatically it sounds like
i'm going to talk about him regaling
this old army memory but it just
it turns into a dumb deck job I'm doing
last night it was a good dick when i
telled their jokes now they're about my
dick you know what I mean yeah by the
way let me ask you this let me let me
ask you this do you feel like because
what and and this is the thing about
having a set like the one I had like
late night is that I um I feel like oh
[ __ ] man you know i don't know if i
should be so serious like I think i'm
suffering lately maybe my whole life but
I I'm conscious of it now that like I
wanna make I want to do serious stuff
would stand up and talk about serious
things but I realize that you have to
have a lightness about like if I take it
too seriously I'm gonna get [ __ ] you
know a great I agree and I keep my light
ridiculous jokes I thought of a few new
ones where I'm just mad about owls or
things that don't rubble yeah just uh
just ridiculous jokes that I really
don't have any emotion about but I it's
been harder for me to come up with them
lately but I still pepper them through
it because it you gotta maintain that
I'm new I'm a goofy ridiculous person
right yeah yeah you do and and then but
I like to be like that angry like I want
to be you know and I am like like the
angry guy but he's silly to like yeah
really silly like i like i want to use
my anger to fuel like I want the message
to be that I'm ridiculously angry well
you do do that yeah yeah I do i do I can
tell you're angry but Angli I know
you're angling at anger but then you at
the end there's that little smile that
lets say ya know like I'm kidding like
your new with the hat you spent I think
25 minutes with your new hat that
special is so good and holy win in ruins
yeah yeah it's really great um and but
you get you do gala get mad and they
know they're all on board you know
you're not really angry but like like
like that's one of the ways i have like
keyed into comedy is through vocal and
emotion like like I if I like I admire
the guys who like can just do one
miners and like do a whole set of
basically kind of like even keel like I
have to really throw myself into it to
want to be in front of people in a while
since I've seen a comic like that
because I like that kind of comedy too
but for a full hour to maintain and like
once you go on the road because I used
to that was my goal be like i'll have
like even pre twitter i'm like wanted
twitter type jokes short yeah that had
Bergie type jokes and it's so hard to
pull off for a long time yeah you have
to excuse me who I'm just dying that's
all yeah yeah you have to have stories
I'm trying everyone wants to hear
stories now that crowds want to hear
about you it's like a new thing is it
yeah I think so I they really want you
to be honest they want to know about
your life I used to think it was
presumptuous for me to assume that
people want to hear about me perfectly
right commitment LOL tell jokes isn't a
little scary like oh you want to hear
about my life all right well I got up
today and I I just stared out the window
hmm for like two hours I am I am going
to talk about like depression and
suicidal thoughts and things like that
but I haven't tackled other stuff I'm
like I'm stepping into it yeah but I do
I see right away that it's it's means
more and people know because one of the
other comics I want to tell you that one
of the other comics I listened to in
this little um because I'm like I came
home from that show going okay I gotta
learn yeah I gotta learn I got us and I
just picked other guys and I picked
Canaan and I was I listened to his last
thing called with whiskey icarus is is
Chris you know and anyway it's great and
it's really good and he tell story yeah
does tell stories but they're about
little here's what they aren't that
revealing really they are they aren't
like like little stories about the guy
sitting next is Canaan I'm on a plane
right I'm on a plane flying a fly on
plane and here i am i'm mr. gonna fly
and next to me comes a guy with a bag
and what is in this bag
hand cakes and the whole story and he
does it brilliantly is about a guy who
has a bag of pancakes and canaan then
goes so what the [ __ ] this guy gets up
most people on the day they fly they're
gonna be like okay I gotta get that
plane not this [ __ ] guy he's gonna
get pancakes in a bag anyway it's just
it's so it's a story but I realized they
don't have to be on because I'm sober
you don't believe he's stealing [ __ ] I
mean I have a I have a joke about
getting on the city bus and some kid at
the helmet rule classic whole class of
kids like fifth grade class gets on the
bus there's no room for him but the bus
drivers just angrily lets them all on
and this kid is pushed by his friends to
where he's sitting on my lap and the
whole time he's holding a bag of
spaghetti with noodles and sauce and
it's not it's not a ziploc bag it's not
even bound at the thai it's just his
little saucy fist holding this plastic
thing so like at the I don't so I'm I
want to talk about the why his mom is
like you bring home spaghetti for your
brother basically the same type of thing
at lunch late it's like share i'll give
you some spaghetti and he's dabbing it
every time we balanced around a little
dab of the bag would put sauce on my
pants and he just kept saying sorry I
know you I don't know there's no ending
to it out that the end the pain weaves
the right hole it's beautiful what he
does and but i but but it is the same
type of thing where you're exactly right
the premise is holding a bag of
inappropriate food like Renault one
break that's great that is so funny to
me that a kid came up with you and then
again he he turned and looked at there
is no punchline I didn't make anything
up yet cuz the end is him going I'm
sorry I got spaghetti on your pants haha
sweet little boy and I wanted to I don't
know him and raised him I loved him
maybe it was really sweet like I should
have a kid but yeah it was it's uh yeah
the inappropriate food on a bus in
appropriate food
no in public and he was talking about
the way the guy then Kinane went into um
and it's all minutia so these stories
are like minutiae of life events I think
crowds like that I don't think they
necessarily want to hear profess to be
right but they want like like kind of
observation of stories and observations
yeah you know arm well if you think back
there are stories I tell I I did that
recently I was like what stories do I
tell friends what are my big hits at a
party complete with my big that'd be
funny like Chris getting ready for a
party alright I gotta tell the story
about stealing okay when I was younger
cuz i already put chips in a bowl so i
gotta let me figure out what stories
I'll tell it this part let's see all
hold it Margaret's coming she heard that
one yeah you made you go to the people
who are coming like oh [ __ ] no I can
tell they're from Colorado I could tell
that cabin story ya hear your stories
are demographically tailored well I
can't tell that that ends in me hating
their exact race oh I will tell me
whatever that's a racist version of me
doing what you would I want it yeah but
you know what i like about that style
though is that the story tell the story
telling it fills time yeah [ __ ] yeah yes
I've done I've done shows where I'm like
I've already I'm a half hour in I told
two stories yeah it's amazing and you
can pepper jokes throughout so it's
right others know that's the beauty of
it and that's what Kyle was doing I was
just boom boom boom yeah whereas then I
listened to Demetri Martin mmm and he is
kind of like one-liner one-liner yeah
yeah liner one lie I didn't listen to
the whole hour but I you know it was
just like boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom and I was like wow like I can't I
can't do that I i now have started to
write I think the perfect blend is
storytelling and jokes it I think so too
i haven't figured out how advanced in a
moment i I really do make an
announcement where I'm like
well that was a bunch of jokes here this
is about my actual life like I tell them
to sweat because I don't know yet how to
because if you have a bunch of jokes
about purple heart or whatever and that
is all fabricated it's all ridiculous
except for some military background in
my family but right right right what
right it does come from a place yeah
what was your dad in the military yeah
reserves I think then he went to art
school he'd never it wasn't bad little
never got a purple art never took
picture of his Rawls all rights fair but
then I try and tell an actual story that
from beginning to end is all real so how
do I if the crowd doesn't trust me
they're like now he's making some of
that up no this story is actually all of
it so I have to announce that [ __ ] Ivan
figured out how to weave them all
together so I don't think you have to
like like you announce that this is what
do you know I just do what I used to
always do which is joke joke joke me and
her fake mess up what that's the first
10 minutes because that gets the crowd
and once I have them where I want them
then I've been messing up with the
format which is me admitting I don't
know what my voice is right now I'm at
this transition stage we just I want to
tell stories now I want ed and I've been
coming up with them mainly because they
fill the time but uh but then after that
I'm like oh here's all these jokes based
on tweets I've written that I also want
to tell and then I go bounce back to one
liners it's kind of there's no flow to
my act you are finding likely you are in
a transition stage in your yeah you're
looking for but you know what I you got
to go on the road to figure that out
though you can't do it popping around
little spots around why they're too
little there too little yeah I'm slots
yeah well when I do sets in town now I'm
like I'm gonna tell these stories or I'm
going to tell these new short Twitter
word-based jokes because i like both but
it's two different right types of comedy
and you know you brought up a couple of
good points because i find that I'm the
funniest around friends like other
comedian friends like I'll come up which
and even just us talking today like the
[ __ ] neocon clown whether that'll
come of anything yeah we are gonna
hahaha but you know what I mean like
like it's your funny you know the people
you're with your [ __ ] hanging with a
bow bow bow bow it's when I try to sit
down in
right did get sad sometimes yeah or i
get really i cant that way there are
people i know that can sit down and and
right i think the really good ones can i
was reading this article yesterday about
George Carlin mmm like one of his last
interviews and man that guy was he would
just sit down and [ __ ] right and he
loved the advent of computers because
Carlin yes doing it way before computers
and then computers k and he loved
writing on computers because of the way
he could flip text around and put things
next to each other then you know he'd
write a whole shitload of stuff and then
go oh no this belongs here right cut and
paste was he loved it do you are you a
twitter person d am I do challenge
yourself to come up with jokes that way
yeah and do you worry anymore about
firing him out there and so anyone could
just grab them I don't worry about them
either I think does tip I've asked her
my roommate yes she's just recently on
Twitter right yeah but she has other
people do it and I voted yet they do
they're people that she doesn't even
know people are just handing around
passing around her password and I'm
saying like random people that was
hilarious I asked her because we I open
for in San Diego and it was fun to catch
up because I'd live with her so many
years seven years and then she was like
I don't know what the password is that
is not I just approved gave it to
someone I think serif started it and now
it's like dirt burglar and open mic nerd
burglar have you seen his work very good
old school but he's a kid he's very good
nerd nerd is finding he has a boyfriend
pull them off staged with a bamboo cane
nerd birth by the way nert fur Fleur
could be a great character for you and
there's another way you can do stand-up
is character like folks and you could
even announce it to the crowd because I
like that I never even thought of
announcing folks I've been experimenting
lately you just break out of what you've
been doing let's say stories or one life
I've been experimenting with characters
lately I hope you don't mind I'm gonna
just do a character I hope you enjoy it
I mean I know we're here in Philadelphia
where you hate everything but and I'm
having a great set and I Love You you
Hey
I love you you love me anyway anyway
you're fresh anyway I'm gonna do cat but
but announced you're gonna do a
character like ya know Burt Fleur I had
a Scott and a hat one time it crackers
in Indianapolis I was having a rough
week and I my last set without
announcing it I just did my whole set
with a southern accent I just told my
jokes does the way I tell him where did
the same but with this voice not a month
at a mustache and I guess where these
sweaters and so they all they bought and
I did way better that's that person and
in the end just to stick it to him I hot
this is how I actually talk that was a
little and they were like very
disappointed that I tricked them the
whole time but that can get rid that is
how that Dan Whitney guy used to be did
Whitney keith larry the cable guy that
was a character he did and then club oh
yeah it was pretty fun i like the
observational stuff where you pretended
to be a train track or what but we like
the redneck you did wow I didn't know
that yes so Dan Whitney I don't know and
with these his day oh look look look him
up online Simone he's wearing a
turquoise wine shirt and he's got
feathered hair and he's he's he's doing
blue collar e-type shows Wow on the road
with Foxworthy or whatever yeah yeah
yeah but he was not larry the cable guy
that was a character that's get er done
get er done yeah night are done oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] i wish i could come up with a
one-word catchphrase like Halliburton is
killing us and you know just like just
like you know ah that should be it is an
average guy but however he telling us
he's politically hip like he's like like
god damn it Margaret wearing my soy my
pills made of soy which by the way my
cell should not be making food Allen
burns killed us see you later and it
causes inflammation in some blood types
ask your doctor Halliburton but Lee
that's how he said feta saying goodbye
he just goes like that's his like you
know when he's wherever he is he's like
instead of saying goodbye he's like al
burns get on us don't forget to come
over for the corn tomorrow it's made by
Monsanto everything he talks about is
corporate malfeasance but it done in a
very kind but anyway there's so many
different ways anyone to do it right so
we shouldn't feel but we feeI i feel i
should say you but I feel so confined
sometime I'd like doing character I just
don't know how I would do it during
scanned about it's an ambition thing
I've got so in a way you [ __ ] just
say I'm gonna do my jokes guys I've been
[ __ ] around with characters deal by
if you a present it like that they'll be
like okay [ __ ] around with characters
I'm thinking what do you think and this
is a character I call photographer who
likes to be semi nude yeah yeah and then
I think I'm ripping off TJ Miller
someone else I've seen oh so I feel like
when it's a character thing I'm like
people have done this people have done
it better than me a bill hader and I
made it a Perez Nell at the same time
and then married my ex girlfriend so why
would I the wire actors oh yeah worm I
wear my t-shirt on Saturday Night Live
guy remember yeah what kind of man well
that's a real story and people think I
made it up but that's [ __ ] real holes
Oh was there love and they got they got
kids they're both great decent people
but i remember being Dave wrath my
manager at the time got this this at the
fake gallery just put up a green screen
and we did these characters and there's
some other girl did some characters for
your real or something yeah it out
what's recive L you know it was just
during that time and then I heard well
I've watched him and I'm like that guy
does a perv you know it was Al Pacino
and Swartz and anger and stuff and some
interesting ones treat Williams I think
he did that guy don't know why the hater
yet he just did a bunch but that I'm
like that's what people do on that's now
what am i doing stand-up and then
dancing around like Ellen DeGeneres for
a minute but he yeah I was like okay
that guy does that so in my head I feel
like I can't do characters cuz there's
people out there that legit that's you
know oh yeah that's
wrong now yeah yeah you do what I do in
and I you you battle those [ __ ]
voices that tell you as soon as you have
something that you like actually like it
probably appeals to you to do characters
yeah I so as soon as jump there you're
gonna do this you absolutely do you
think I'm pretty good at race clothes as
soon as you [ __ ] up something you
like no no no no no you don't get to do
that Chris no no no you I could create
an obstinate for myself I don't know
dark things are things I don't have a
lot of memory Oh was it like growing up
in out by the way we have about maybe 10
minutes and i'm about to ask you what
was it like growing up in my dad like me
because I there's no I don't have any
complaints it was yeah in retrospect I'm
really thankful that I grew up there and
I've been going back a lot yeah
beautiful your family still there yeah
my dad's still there my sister and mom
are in Spokane but it's close right
Washington very the part of Montana I'm
from was just the western edge all
mountains and the high it's beautiful
country it's beautiful it's undeniably I
go back and it's the town I grew up in
went to college in and I'm like this
place what town is gorgeous Missoula oh
I've been to Missoula yahoo very pretty
yeah it would be funny of in your head
you're like it wasn't that great
hahahaha round certainly don't play a
lot no I just Todd Barry and I did shows
there a couple weeks ago and they were
great and I was like AG better tell some
dick show these guys don't watch a lot
of stand up so I should be and they're
like we prefer you to be smart and they
were the most savvy and they never get
stand up there but they were fans of
Todd Barry yeah they've done their
research and you know the Apple music
the I time they were good it was great
and it was beautiful it's funny growing
up there though I just want to live here
I was born here and so I just wanted to
move to California and be a surfer
skater guy and now that I'm here and I
do live at the beach I'm like man
Montana was great I'm glad I grew up
there but you let you live on the west
side that's kind of cool yeah yeah it's
the best place I gotta lie there and it
makes me late for everything right I
don't do stand-up as much as I could
150 degrees like where I live ruining my
career but it's not as hot as in North
Hollywood yeah it's so ruining like
living at the beach of course you know
you know why I had that I'll be right
where Canaan is right now our old album
went out at the same time we were neck
and neck on iTunes I had a banner ad
before him I had to stay at the beach he
also is a hard worker possibly better
writer and undeniably more funny than
David the point is I could be the Road
Dogg he travels and works I be a road
dog yeah but but I had that feeling too
I lived in Venice when I first got to LA
I lived in Venice for the first three
months and I had this thought that if I
stayed here I would just have what i
call beach brain yeah I wouldn't want to
do anything yeah I just would want to be
stoned in a drum circle you don't I do
that every once a while and i skate
there's skate parks there and I'd
skateboard a lot I used to get caught up
in it more and yeah wow I haven't done
stand-up for three weeks so that's that
doesn't happen anymore I'll cool yeah
but so it's not like you get addicted to
that but it's nice to have that option
of drum circle absolutely dispensary
it's just nice to be by the water it's
great ice my hip I have a bad hip yeah
and I've been swimming in the ocean just
hold saltwater swimming yeah like
kicking like a frog like it doesn't it
looks like I'm drowning actually some
people have tried to save me it's just
the way I swim do you so you swim in
santa monica over there right at the end
of washington i live on that street and
it's right there to peer there it's the
it's marina del rey oh ok ok sounds you
got very serious it's marina del rey and
uh you know there's a lot of bars at the
end there yeah yeah but I do swim in the
ocean my roommate always does that's
enough do you surf I know Elwood's I
would I don't know grandma was a pretty
good surfer yeah he still been yeah he's
like legit legitimate sorry for all of
his gear and board and everything or
from the 90s but good for like an early
90s comedian surfer I'm a
I ax I I have too much pressure on
myself because I was a decent
skateboarder and a decent snowboarder
but you're hurting him yeah I think then
it's no wearing that I got in a car
wreck after right leaving Conan I did
Conan left oh that went well at a
stoplight a guy hit us from me and my ex
girlfriend at 50 miles right now I'm and
out of the studio told the car squished
the car and and then so I laid in bed
for like a month during the time when he
shouldn't be like hey comedy clubs I did
Conan I didn't even watch it to all week
so at that I think is why my I think
just in recovering from that I start
walking a little weird whatever so I've
been swimming but uh but Sir hold it the
lesson here is don't do Conan for a lot
of young kids out there you want the
exposure but it's too goddamn risky
that's street cahuenga or barham I can't
remember which because I hit my head
pretty good oh man it's down hills right
by the way that's another thing that
scares the [ __ ] out of me in la i'm
getting rear-ended well every time I get
in a car out here I'm like here we go
really nice here we go it is scary to
drive here do you drive what did you for
a long time not operate a vehicle no no
I've always i also have an hilarious
about me is there anything at ippoliti
yes Paula yeah that didn't didn't drive
but I i got i lived in new york city for
like i grew up in a suburb so i was
driving but then i moved to like
manhattan brooklyn and I I didn't try
for many years yeah and then I came to
LA I had I had a passed my road test in
New York and I did that just before I
came to LA and I came too late got off
the plane and was haven't driven in 20
years basically and just throwed it to
La Strada the most overwhelming I still
I just sometimes I just pull over and
walk into a bar hahaha where it's just
like I [ __ ] [ __ ] you people and I just
pull over and just go in and get a
couple whiskey's never worry about
that makes things worse I'd get a uber
I'd end up taking an uber that's what I
do that's what I do yeah man yeah um
this podcast sponsored by over alright
so Chris thank you so much I feel like
that I ended on a weird note knows I
said that maybe I drink too much but
that was really cool man and so um let's
see you we can follow you just at Chris
Fairbanks on twitter again that's where
i talk about local gigs and um you got
anything coming up do you want to do it
time I just coming out next door so okay
it was that'll be october october 24 I
gotta talk to Ted it shows during her
wedding I said I'd go to wear wet on Jen
why she's are you coming to my wedding
I'm you have an RSVP time like of course
of course I'm very well I have these
shows in Denver uh and they've already
sold tickets they promoted it I can't I
don't come and I want to do it Tigs
wedding and I want to do it yeah and I'm
not someone that's in represent where
I'm like all reschedule it just have me
back I'm like oh boy I get it yeah
anyway from you know i'm wanting fourth
i'm doing three kings tavern in denver
and some other knives like the guy gotta
talk to TIG no I got Justin now so maybe
listen I got a caller it be so funny
it's been on there's people in Denver
who's like who would like just following
it going what's the progress on
Fairbanks and the TIG wedding like they
haven't boys they're waiting to buy
tickets and they I must have misheard
him on the pep talks podcast I thought I
was coming to a wedding mm-hmm and I'm
and don't forget to listen to chris and
caren kill garrus podcast do you need a
ride and you're part of the old things
comedy network yeah yeah yes and i'm
going to i think we should record in
here with car sounds in the background
that's a good idea that would be [ __ ]
lame easier and don't forget to rate
this podcast pep talks on itunes give it
five stars we let me know what you think
of the show email me at I Pepitone eep
eep itoe @ sbcglobal.net remember
they're made by Halliburton thanks and
we'll be back next week see you then
Halliburton skillet us
Oh what's up food this is philippe as
far as on the watts or poop podcast
check out my new web series i created
for earthlings conroe it's called a shop
starts Monday October fear it's about
two guys who work at a marijuana
dispensary new episodes come out every
monday at noon pacific time watch at
youtube.com slash atc
you